あのー
ｳｩｯ
ｳｩﾌｩ―――――――（泣
ｳｩﾎ――――――――
ﾎﾊｯ（鼠
ﾎﾊﾊｯ（鼠
ﾎｯﾎーｩ
あのー
なんでこうなったのかという経緯を説明しますと
バナナがたくさん欲しいなと言ったのは紛れもなく
僕です
たくさんバナナ１００房ぐらい買って
たくさんバナナがあったら
どのバナナが一番甘いのかなと思って
聞いたんですよ！
なんかお店の人に聞いたんですよ
お店の人に聞いたらなんか
１房あたり５,６本ですよみたいな感じで言われて
あ、そうなんですねって
５,６本じゃ
ないやないか―――い!!
全然５,６本じゃないやないかぁ
ｹﾞｯﾍｪ
全然５,６本じゃない！
だって５,６本とかじゃないじゃん
これおかしいでしょ
13 , 14 , 15
おかしいでしょー
まあまあ まあ 問題はない
検証の対象が増えただけ
僕は今からこの大量ｎ
これドンキーコングやないかい
スーファミのドンキーコングのスタートの家の下みたいになってるわ
バナナ
いろんなバナナがここにあるんですけども
このバナナの中でどれが一番甘いか
おいしいか
糖度が高いか
調べていこうと思います
たぶんですね
甘いバナナって
見た目でわかるんですよ
なんかちょっと知らべてみよ
甘いバナナの見分け方みたいな
シュガースッポット！
黒い斑点の多いバナナは
やっぱり甘いみたいですね
あと
大きいバナナは
おいしいのかな
ほぉ～
え !?
破裂すんの !?!?
破裂....
よくわかんない
常識的に考えて
太くて大きいバナナ♂％×＃...
ｗ（照
なんか常識的に考えて
太くて大きいバナナの方がおいしいらしいです
エロいね！
まあ現状態で一番甘いバナナを食べようと思います
これだけバナナがあればもう
異常においしい個体がいてもおかしくないと思うんで
とりあえず １房の中で
一番おいしそうなバナナを見つけます
それぞれ
で その中から一番おいしいやつを選んでいきましょう
では　イこう！
めんどくせぇな...
なんかそもそも房の数がちょっとおかしくて
１００房あるんですよ
で今だいたい数えると
一房あたり１５本から１８本あるんで
ま、少なく見て１５×１００
１５００本あります
あああああああああああ
ハイ というわけで各房の代表が決まりましたー
（ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ）
ハイ というわけで
こちらが今回の
房の予選を勝ち抜いた代表の皆様でーす
おめでとうございまーす（棒
はいそして こちらが今回
予選敗退されるバナナの皆様です
お疲れ様でしたー
しばらくそこの観覧席で試合をご覧ください
約１００房のバナナたちがそろったんですけども
ここからは
ナンバー１を決めるわけなんで
神聖なチェック(?)が必要なので
こちらの糖度計
バナナの正確な糖度を計っていこうと思います
どーやって計るんだろう
まーとりあえずこれだな たぶんきっと
糖度が出ると思うんで
乗せてなんかやれば糖度が出る みたいなやつでしょ？
代表の房の皆様の糖度を計って
ナンバー１の甘さを持つバナナを
決めていこうと思います！
彼がNo.１
あ あ えっえっえっ
まってまってまって
マジで数字で見える
20...
に...じゅう..さん
頑張っていきまーす
ぎょおおあ
これ31だな...
匂う やっぱ凄いのってすごいんだなー
はーい！
というわけで
無事
全部の代表の
糖度の調査が終わりましたぁー！
はいというわけで
神聖なる(?)
糖度を
の、計測による結果
えー
ファイナリスト
ちょっとこう
ひと際抜いて
頭角をあらわして
甘かったバナナたちを呼んで来ようと思います
ファイナリストの皆様
どうぞ！！！
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
エントリーナンバー24(34)番
エントリーナンバー72番
そして
エントリーナンバー76番！
こちらの３組は本当に！
甘さの数値がぶっ壊れてました
とても高い三組でございます
まあ共通点としては
なんか なんだろう
やっぱ 多少のシュガースッポトは必須ですね
ちょっと黒くなっているのも必須なんですけども
それ以上にこの２本に関してはデカい♂！
異常にでかいです
ただなんか 34番に関しては小さいんですね
だからなんか太さにか関係なく
甘いものは甘いのかなっていう気がしました
最後は僕が食べて判断してみようと思います
では 32番からいただきます！
いただきます
ﾊﾟｸｯ
ﾓｸﾞ..ﾓｸﾞ..
続いては７２番です
いただきます
ﾊﾟｸｯ
ﾓｸﾞ..ﾓｸﾞ..
最後７６番いただきます！
ﾊﾟｸｯ
ﾓｸﾞ..ﾓｸﾞ..ﾓｸﾞ..ﾓｸﾞ..
はいというわけで３つ食べ終わりました
もうなんか
食った瞬間
これ違うなっていうのあったんで
もう僕の中の１位は決まってます
第一位は
ﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹﾃﾞｹ
ｼｬｰﾝ
エントリーナンバー
何番だ？
エントリーナンバー３４番
バナナでーーーーーーーす
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
いや もう この ビッグサイズの2本をさし置いて
こっちがとてもおいしかったです
うん
全然こっちの方がうまいです
ま、全部同じなんだけどね
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑  ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
この～動画見～て～
だいぶー前～
バナナー買って～た～
の思い～出～して
冷蔵庫～か～ら
出・し・た・ら
ま・っ・く・ろ☆